Theo Vaughn was just a guest on a
hilarious episode of two bears one cave
with Tom segora and that video is
already well over 2 million views on
YouTube but Tom's episode with the Rat
King isn't even in the top three most
viewed guest Bears because when Andrew
huberman went on the show he racked up
over 4 million views which is a million
more than the second place episode
featuring Tom Segura and Quentin
Tarantino but right behind that one is
Tom and Tim Dillon at 3 million followed
by the time that Joe Rogan stopped by
ymh Studios to talk with Tom and arm
wrestle the staff two bears one cave has
been having on a lot more guests since
Bert and Tom started Living in different
cities a few years ago including some
big time comedians like Andrew Santino
and Bobby Lee Louis CK and most recently